good morning oh come on you guys good
morning okay much better I'm Karen
kinsman and for the last 16 years I've
been the director of the stem center at
the United United University of New
Mexico managing outreach programs
educator professional development and
competitions predominantly for
pre-college students my educational
background is in psychology and
management I get asked all the time are
you a scientist and I say no and that's
really good when you run STEM
competitions because nobody can ever
accuse you of stepping in and overriding
judges decisions because I have no idea
what I'm talking about I've been mostly
involved in nonprofit management and
leadership and program development for
the last thirty years for most of that
time I probably like you guys have
struggled with how to truly know if what
we do it really has its intended impacts
we're all doing good perhaps great
perhaps awesome work but how do we
really know that right we know that
intrinsically probably and we hear it
but how do we really know so spoiler
alert I don't know and I haven't found
the Holy Grail and I haven't met anybody
who's found the Holy Grail either so
let's see if this sounds familiar and
you're gonna think I'm a little crazy
but close your eyes for a second imagine
this you and your team have worked
tirelessly to offer outreach programs
for students attendance is great maybe
sometimes not-so-great
students seem to be genuinely engaged
and they're post-event surveys bear that
out the students and maybe even families
or teachers if your audiences
pre-college are over overheard talking
about how awesome the event was how much
they learned and perhaps even that it
changed how they see their own futures
their survey answers seem to indicate
that your event really made them think
positively about STEM careers they can
see themselves as a scientist or an
engineer or a programmer or a physician
you're also fairly certain that a number
of your participants are also
participating
similar programs offered by other
organizations doing outreach in your
area
you always wonder which program is
having more impact it must be yours
right
or if participating in more than one
experience over time is what actually
creates lasting impact okay you can open
your eyes now I won't make you close and
further us at the time any of that sound
familiar to anybody vaguely
okay so here's one of the first big
questions that came up for me and doing
the pre-work how can we best measure the
effectiveness and impact of our programs
to me to funders to our partners to our
stakeholders I think that's the
million-dollar question sometimes quite
literally the million dollar question or
some of us hope it's a million it may be
more like a thousand so I'm gonna
disappoint you one more time by
admitting I don't have that answer
either I have discussed this very topic
what seems hundreds of times in the past
16 years with a collection of cross
sector partners we have searched for
answers and it seems we mostly just keep
adding to our list of questions here are
just a few of our other unanswered ones
see if any of them ring true for you how
do we really know that what we're doing
has any long-term lasting impact how do
we know if the biggest impact comes from
one program one event or participating
in multiple programs over time how do we
even approach the idea of defining
impact how might that definition change
give in different contexts let me throw
out a couple more words you might
recognize and I'm betting that some of
you are gonna cringe anecdotal data oh
and thank you Jeannie for my new
vocabulary word annek data I love that
so annek data is my new vocabulary word
for our organization and I would venture
to guess many of yours as well anecdotal
data is a very informative and powerful
metric for us as practitioners but is
not necessarily highly valued or lacks
credibility amongst funders and related
agencies because
it is not considered hard data right
it's not numbers necessarily how do we
go about working with funders and other
agencies to legitimize the very real
anok data that we receive from our
participants I know
another unanswered question let me throw
something else at you and this was
another kind of theme in my pre-work was
data sharing any of you ever talk about
data sharing with colleagues what's your
reaction to those two words mine was oh
god that's a big hairy beast that big
hairy beast brings with it even more
questions and unfortunately not a whole
lot of solid answers at least in where I
exist so things like how do we make it
feasible to share data across
organizations or institutions when we
serve the same or similar populations
this would allow us to perhaps track
participants who engage in multiple
programs to help us determine if or how
that participation impacts for instance
their decision to pursue a stem career
but we seem to make it extraordinarily
difficult to actually share information
even and I heard this conversation at my
breakfast table and I hear it at my work
all the time even at our own
institutions we cannot figure out how to
share information you know god forbid we
share information and figure out that we
could actually develop collective impact
and increase how we impact other people
but we can't do that because you might
take my funding or you might take my
idea or I might take yours which is not
the point and I come from the nonprofit
world outside of academia until 16 years
ago and that's totally not how it works
in the nonprofit world for the most part
for the most part we're all about
getting together and figuring out how to
share stuff because there's limited
stuff out there but for whatever reason
we can't figure that out in academia and
I'm not there's my other caveat I'm not
an academic either which is probably why
I don't understand that
if we could share data what data would
be worth sharing what data would
actually inform our practices and make
the most impact
are there feasible ways to share
participant data across organizations
and institutions here's a big question
that's come up in our cross sector
partnership discussions who would own
the data all right here's another one is
IRB approval required and if yes see
you're laughing - and if so who's IRB
will be consulted and will IRB is that
other partner institutions accept the
decision of another institutions
committee I dare you to repeat that
that's been a pretty recent conversation
in our our cross sector partnership
group how and where would the data be
secured what data would actually
illuminate trends for us that would
really make a difference and how do we
engage with alumni of our programs after
they've graduated and gone into higher
education or into the workforce I have a
counterpart at UNM who actually works on
the undergraduate side of the world we
have no way of knowing if any of the
students that he's working with as
freshmen and sophomores participated in
my programs and whether or not their
participation in our programs before
they went to college impacted their
interest in stem got it almost done so
the list goes on and on as a community
of practitioners and stem outreach I
think we have yet to be able to truly
answer those questions well I don't know
about you but when we seem to get close
to answering some of the questions we
just come up with more that need to be
answered and I cannot imagine we're
alone so I have a single example about
sharing anecdotes of how we figure out
if students are participating in our
programs with other organizations I have
one stellar student who's been with us
since she was in sixth grade and I just
found out by happenstance that she's
participating in another organizations
programs and is actually teaching
younger students science but I wouldn't
know that except for I was sitting at a
table in another context all together
with the educator from that organization
who said oh I think you might know
Michaela
huh yeah I do I took her to the
International Science Fair twice so how
do we get beyond our questions can we
develop solutions that are useful across
a variety of outreach programs and can
can we find our way past obstacles real
and perceived that keep us from truly
being able to take advantage of the
amazing opportunities that could exist
to create collective impact that could
really move the needle for our
participants
I think we're here to try to start
finding solutions to at least a few of
our shared unanswered questions and I'm
so excited to see what we can come up
with together so let's do it
you